all right we'll start with this from fox
8 maybe you've heard this story but
here's the latest a woman who came into
close contact with an escaped monkey on
the side of an interstate in
pennsylvania said she developed pink
eye-like symptoms and is now on
preventative medication
wonderful
a truck hauling uh 100 monkeys from
africa was headed to a lab in missouri
when it collided with a dump truck on
fri friday at uh on route 54 in
interstate 80 in valley township
michelle fallon of danville said she
pulled over to help the driver
fallon said i thought i was just doing
the right thing by helping i had no idea
it would turn out this way he just asked
if his trailer was okay he never said if
you do come to your crate don't touch it
if he would have told me that i would
have been more careful
that's when she came face to face with
an agitated monkey which hissed in her
face
three monkeys and all in all escaped
during the ordeal during the search
officials warned the public not to come
near the monkeys because they would
transmit disease
she said quote i was close to the
monkeys i touched the crates i walked
through their feces so i was very close
so i called to inquire was i safe and um
then apparently she was told by the cdc
that uh you know well basically the cdc
told her yeah maybe not you might not be
safe actually so monitor your symptoms
and um and she has now she's developing
symptoms so
fantastic now
a couple couple things here
just a good rule of thumb that um
hopefully
it will never most of us won't get to a
point where we're gonna have to actually
put this into action but a good rule of
thumb if you do encounter a situation
like this is um
don't help clean up spilled monkeys on
the highway
that's a that's a good rule now i do put
a lot of the blame on the driver here
he's the one that got into the accident
and also he didn't think to mention
when some woman
gets out of her car and comes over and
says hey how you doing everything okay
and then he he asks her
if everything's okay in the back of the
truck and doesn't even mention oh by the
way
this truck is full of virus-infected
monkeys so get the hell away from us
so i put a lot of the blame on him and i
don't mean to victim blame here but the
moment that you see
that there are cages with animals inside
them
don't go anywhere near them just get in
your car and drive away
uh there are there are people who are
supposed to be equipped to deal with
these kinds of situations and it's not
you
i think the great the greater issue here
is that
this is
that we know of
at least maybe the third occasion where
potentially a virus has escaped from a
lab
or a virus that was headed to a lab
escapes on its way there
we know about the big one in wuhan
and there are some very good indications
that although no one has told us this
and they probably never will officially
tell us just like they haven't
officially admitted it in wuhan and
never will but there are indications
that uh omnicorn escaped from a lab or
somehow got out of a lab in in south
africa
and now we've got this here if you feel
like you are getting the respect you
deserve in life well i've got a solution
for you establish titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland and your title pack
you'll receive at least one square foot
of dedicated land on a private estate
and an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and the best
way to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends of boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles as having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established dot
com slash matt walsh or just click the
link below so this this is what this is
what
gets me
uh if i want to build
a patio in my backyard i need to get 37
permits to do it
because of all the the safety concerns
apparently of having a patio in my own
backyard at our old house
we were doing renovations inside our
home
and somebody from the county showed up
because i guess
a very helpful neighbor noticed that we
had a lot of
construction workers and things coming
in and out of the house and they decided
very helpfully to call the county and
alert them and so this guy from the
county shows up saying hey what are you
guys doing here what's going on
what am i doing here um it's none of
your business
it's in our house get the hell off my
property
you creep
so that's what happens if you try to you
know do anything in your own home try to
build a patio
uh
you know renovate inside or outside of
your home
god forbid you try to build some kind of
extension on your home
the permitting process for that is
basically impossible
probably 90 of people and i know this
from experience who've even thought
about building any kind of addition or
extension on their home ninety percent
probably give up
because once they realize how many
permits they have to get just to do it
how expensive and complicated the
process is
so that's what if you wanna you know
that's that's everyday life for just
regular americans even in your own home
then you talk to business owners
all the red tape they have to clear all
the permits and licenses and everything
they have to get and then get renewed
and everything else
all of the ridiculous oversight the
bureaucracies they have to navigate
and yet these virus labs are allowed to
just
deposit
dangerous pathogens all over the planet
and no one just there's no
accountability
nobody even gets a fine
has anybody even been fined has there
even been like a 50 fine
for killing 5 million
people letting a virus out in wuhan has
has that has that even happened
and now you've got
monkeys that all have viruses and you
put them in the back of just a truck
a regular truck and bring it down the
highway
and there's no
there's no oversight process there
apparently i guess that's that's you
know that's less dangerous than me
building a patio or me building a fence
that's over four feet tall or whatever
the arbitrary limit is for when you're
perfect for those things well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content